I'll bet you didn't know that in the 70s
high school sex education was arguably
more progressive than it is today yeah
sex ed is so limited in today's schools
in fact that 28 states don't even
require it to be taught and only 13
states require that sex ed instruction
be medically accurate mostly meaning
that it should be accurate about the
effectiveness of condoms and with teen
pregnancy and STI rates in the u.s.
substantially higher than in other
developed countries maybe it's time for
a sex ed revolution but just how did sex
ed in the u.s. get so bad in the first
place well the first sex ed curriculum
called sex hygiene classes was
introduced in 1913 in Chicago by a woman
named Ella Flagg young who was also the
first female superintendent of schools
in the city
unfortunately for young and her students
the Catholic Church didn't like this
very much and put an end to her program
after only one year it wasn't until the
u.s. entered World War one that the
government realized it had a major
problem or rather its troops did the
army lost a total of seven million
working days from soldiers suffering
from sti's which back then was called VD
or venereal disease and a total of
10,000 soldiers were discharged for
having them the White House concluded
that so many American soldiers wouldn't
have contracted sti's had they been
better educated about sex in the 20s
upwards of 40% of American public
schools started teaching sex ed which
coincidentally developed just as the
film industry was taking off as
Hollywood booms so did sex ed films
then in the 30s the US Office of
Education began publishing materials and
training teachers on how to teach sex ed
we must continue this important work of
Education and forget our prudish
attitude toward sex
then in 1944 at the height of world war
ii came the mass production of
penicillin saving troops everywhere
suffering from st is passed forward 16
years when the fda approved the pill in
1960 for widespread use it was the
beginning of the sexual revolution of
course americans newfound sexuality
didn't come without backlash in 1968 a
pamphlet called
is the schoolhouse the proper place to
teach raw sex started appearing in
public schools this moral decay weakens
our resistance to the onslaught of the
communist masters of disease and yet
1970s curriculum featured some of the
most explicit films found in sex ed
classes ones they wouldn't likely show
in today's classrooms many different
times of feeling has been called in
erection but by the late 70s the
conservative right started influencing
some parents to protest the curriculum
and then in 1981 the Reagan
administration introduced the adolescent
Family Life Act this law which put a ton
of funding towards sex ed programs that
promoted abstinence was the single
biggest influencer on modern day sex ed
curriculum but research showed that
abstinence only programs that gained
popularity in the 80s and 90s didn't
work teens still had just as much sex
and states with abstinence only
education had the highest rates of teen
pregnancies in fact a 2008 study
reported that teens who received
comprehensive sex education were 60%
less likely to get pregnant than those
who received abstinence only education
so in 2010 Obama cut funding for
abstinence only programs by two-thirds
and for the first time ever the
government began funding comprehensive
sex ed programs you know ones that
actually talked about contraception
today both abstinence only sex ed and
more comprehensive sex ed are equally
funded by the government but with only
18 states and the District of Columbia
requiring those kinds of comprehensive
classes is it time to teach all students
what they really need to know about sex
so you want to go to grad school but you
aren't sure whether it's worth it